duron win all these guys from aka how do
we get these guys
better and how do we get them to check
i'll tell you how to get the ron win
better lose some [ __ ] weight dude
[ __ ]
was like definitely not in his weight
class he a thick boy he could lose some
[ __ ] weight
you better not hear he was he was
yelling at some people in an interview
about it
so he's gonna come beat your ass tell
him what's he going to do beat me up
i was like oh [ __ ] david's about to say
something
like oh [ __ ] exactly what i said i was
like you gotta do beat me up
oh [ __ ] also you got to taper it off a
little bit there but that's
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode
of the genius brain podcast we have the
og crew back we have
nick the [ __ ] mangled ear done
no it's just the ear that's it no no no
no no the wonton ear
done gyoza ear is my favorite gyoza ear
is the best right and then we have
patrick the funny man
i do butt sex but i shame women for it
wow that's pretty cool though yeah i
mean that's
good for about six years they call that
what a double standard right
but you know what that should be your
nickname patrick double standard riley
but he's only having sex like
with butts yeah it sounds like the worst
batman villain ever
like what does he do he just has butt
sex with women feels weird about it
afterwards
and i make them feel bad for it and then
batman's like wait what do you do though
like
hey but to be fair i never made her feel
bad about it we actually just you
we just it's just i mean i just we just
never talked about it
you guys never broke it down like we
just both like ptsd deleted that out of
our system and like hey it was pretty
stinky huh yeah let's just not talk well
you
guys
moved on from there yeah we just didn't
talk about it do you really need to
break that down and be like i mean in
retrospect i wish we would have talked
about it
i should have been like what would you
have said though well first i would have
came back because i
immediately showered i would have came
back would have been a little awkward
and been like
you said you would immediately shout i
had to get the [ __ ] out of there bro i
had to i
had to be done you ran out of the
bedroom i would have came back and been
like
just to break the ice like a lot a lot
of poo poo
is that the green poop story that's the
green right and then just you know break
the ice and talk and be like you know it
is we need a lot of spinach
or pollution yeah a lot of fiber you
know yeah
you have something you're a good diet
you know that's pretty cool vibrant it
should be talked about though it should
be talked about yeah yeah yeah we should
we should address it right now to her
excuse me if you're watching this right
now yeah yeah your poo poo was green
it was a little weird it's okay it's not
the end of the world yes yeah that's
fine
comes out of your butt so you know yeah
well you went to hawaii how was that it
was [ __ ] amazing
and it's funny because uh butt sex is
legal in hawaii really illegal no it's
not wait wait
oh okay why did you why would you listen
to me i think where the [ __ ] would this
guy listen to me dude you're the only
person
that goes to hawaii loses like 10 pounds
yeah i lost i lost like five pounds dude
how the [ __ ] is that about
15 000 steps a day we were walking a lot
we were like swimming we're doing hikes
dude hawaii's [ __ ] magical there's
something about that place
that is just special everybody
spiritually dude
the aloha for hawaii i love it
and if you guys sign up now you swipe up
you can use my promo code to go to
hawaii
nah dude i just loved it man i've never
i've always wanted to go and i was so
hyped to go
and ever it just you know when you have
high expectations for something and it
hits every expectation
i told you that's what it was hawaii is
my home away from home i felt home there
bro people were like oh you're local and
i'm like
god no i'm not oh my god no problem
huh and they're like all right get the
[ __ ] out of my store and i would leave
but uh nah man everybody was so [ __ ]
the locals were so cool
everybody was so cool he asked me like a
couple places to eat i got a few places
in like 30 places yeah and i was like
hey man this is way too many places no
it's not well you're in hawaii and we
did it
hey baby there was a street called ala
papa road and that was my favorite
but uh yeah man it was it was beautiful
everybody was really cool there
um the food was the poke okay
have you been to hawaii yeah i've been
to maui oh dude you got it
maui is very beautiful but oahu got the
food oahu is where it's at yeah that's
where the drinks are
that's where the food is so maui is very
scenic maui is like a mix between big
island and oahu and a little bit of
kauai
so it has like some decent food here
great resorts and a lot of great scenery
i think oahu has a little bit of
everything so if you want to go get
drinks you want to go to bars well you
know pre-pandemic
go to bars good food you can go to the
west side if you want to see more
naturey [ __ ] go to the north shore
but oahu is my favorite island where
it's at yeah yeah see when i went i went
with my buddy jose who's like mexican as
[ __ ] i literally ate
like possole and like [ __ ] chicharron
i literally was like i was a [ __ ]
food wise it was like i was in mexico
bro like that was it i was like why did
you get
that [ __ ] cause his mom lives there
and she would like cook for us and stuff
and they live on maui she lives on maui
yeah so
i ate literally like posole every day
jose once and he had two black eyes bro
he looked [ __ ]
crazy great introduction yeah yeah
that's like what's up
i'm like dude this guy's eyes are shut
closed like
he's like pat warren you are you
couldn't even see you in a mid session
with his face he got punched he got
punched
yeah he got [ __ ] up he's still boxing
and he was still going to train and spar
i was like bro you're out of your mind
ain't nobody trying to box that apple
that looks nuts yeah he looks
nuts he sent me he said he hasn't been
so this dude smokes weed like
religiously he smokes all dabs edibles
throughout the day
oh [ __ ] and uh function he's well that's
just how he functions like that's just
that
he becomes expensive because once you
get high a lot yeah then it takes more
to get you even more high
yeah my science fights the demons inside
me that's honestly exactly what it is so
but
he's been sober he's been sober for like
two weeks now and he posted a picture
the other day like
15 days sober and literally it looked
like he was about to stab a [ __ ]
his eyes were all bloodshot just murder
in his [ __ ] eyes
he's got a message hey bro start smoking
again man yeah that's why you need it
yeah okay
it's like 15 days off is fine yeah now
you can go back and
might be fine there's a lot of people
who function when they smoke weed though
i'm not one of them yeah me neither i
mean
i can't do it i don't know i don't
understand how people can smoke and they
get better as a human being i don't have
that [ __ ]
like my mouth is open and that's it yeah
yeah you become me you become an i
come nick my mouth breather you just
kind of drift off
you know i've been filming like videos
like for like my instagram stuff and i
watch myself and i realize
i go hey i do things that i look
really stupid doing and no wonder people
make fun of me about it like i sometimes
have a dead stare in my eyes and i'm
like
i gotta fix that i look [ __ ] like
r-worded you know like yeah what's the
word again what is it what is that rich
[ __ ] i look [ __ ] oh
no that's just like cut that out cut
that out no no that's going to make that
volume
really loud and just be like wow
no i look dumb as [ __ ] i just look down
oh so you think they're dumb
oh no oh oh we're sdw in your ass right
now
there you go see it's a slippery slope
anybody can get canceled yeah yeah it's
just the right time
especially yeah i think it's the moment
for you right now actually that's fine
yeah
since you've been gone uh what's it
called uh trump is now no longer the
president and biden you weren't even
here uh prior to that huh so we were in
hawaii and uh
when when they were storming the capital
hell yeah and you were like this you
were like
so sunday it was uh the fourth i think
december 4th
sunday we're in pasadena and there's a
rally
a trump rally going on colorado it was
40 minutes of cars just honking
trump flags and i was like what the [ __ ]
is going on i'm trying to pack my board
shorts and [ __ ] you know because i'm
going to hawaii
right and they're driving all the way
through and then on
the news came out in la times the news
you know the news right the news
you heard of news perhaps you heard of
news yes yes yes so and they were saying
like
oh the trump rally the west coast side
started
in pasadena yeah and they drove all the
way to
um the capital and they were trying to
get there by december 6th
and they made their way to the capitol
on december 6th and we're already in
hawaii we're in the hotel
oh they were a part of of that yes they
started in pasadena yeah it was in the
l.a times
yeah i don't know how that's possible
wow but they made it wow that's some
dedication
there were so many people there it was
literally 30 minutes probably even
longer
um but people just driving and
we're sick i'm sitting with all the
hawaiian people in the hotel and they're
just watching the news they're like hey
bro like
what are they doing they're like hey i
guess they're storming the capital dude
they're like where's the swat team
where's the national guard dude the
funniest video
is that dude crying when he's inside the
cap we did
it we did it then he goes now what
which is what everybody was wondering
yeah now did you see
the man or lady that was climbing she
was climbing the wall
i don't know why they were scaling i
don't know the details but she's
climbing the wall
and she like does this cliffhanger thing
where she has two hands up and then she
hangs on one arm
and she looks like she's 87 years old
holy [ __ ]
and she has no business climbing any
wall
or climbing any tree right there and
she's she's hanging on one side and then
she just falls
like and it looked like she died 20 feet
she broke a hip or she died 100
100 she's dead but also what type of
confidence do you have where you think
you could scale a [ __ ] wall
she loves america dude but bro how jack
do you think they were like imagine
being like like you you work at office
depot right you're working nine to five
and then the tomorrow you're in the
capitol building like
you gotta be so for sure they were
taking selfies oh that old lady
[ __ ] climbed a wall you said she was
87 bro she for sure driving the watcher
try to open up a pickle jar and struggle
with that [ __ ] you [ __ ]
but she's she's literally hanging on
dude
she's hanging on with one arm i don't
know if it's a lady or a guy because
at that point it was like it was an
older person that's all i know and gray
hair so that's all i know
and i'm not going to assume anyone's
gender you know what i mean oh this
guy's whoa yeah i'm walking out there
using the artwork yeah yeah i know i
just made a full 180.
you did you did you've evolved in front
of our eyes but this [ __ ] lady you're
back at the same place
but that's the thing it's like why do
people think that they're
scaling walls who do these people think
they are okay should i get some too
yeah absolutely don't pretend don't
pretend what is that cognac
apple juice baby don't worry i like it
but yeah we missed all the good [ __ ] we
missed the capitol building we were we
were in hawaii
and the inauguration was probably i
laughed so [ __ ] hard when
biden had that bible out did you see his
bible i didn't watch the inauguration
bible was like the first bible ever made
it was a scroll
it was it was like leather bound it was
the size
of [ __ ] seven encyclopedias stacked
together wow
and i think it was made of stone was it
was
that's how old that [ __ ] was and it
doesn't help that he's already [ __ ]
old as [ __ ] that's what i'm saying so
the internet was just ripping him one
like dog this full actually brought the
first bible he ever owned he's a
thousand years old
yeah exactly exactly bro bro biden dude
every time he talks i'm like [ __ ] like
he's losing it
like and kamala kamal is just like oh a
couple more days oh yeah
yeah female president of the united
states that's pretty good i think that's
gonna happen that's gonna happen in our
life i think august to win just one gust
of wind in the wrong direction and his
balance is off it's just a rolled ankle
you know like that old people spit in
his mouth where it's a little stringy
and
dry yeah
and then under the mask it's probably
even worse somebody wrote this comment
too they go oh what are you comedians
going to do when trump's not there where
are your jokes going to be at it's going
to be towards bite it yeah
and trump was kind of a godsend like the
things he was doing was like you
couldn't
there was there was no punch line
because you wouldn't believe the [ __ ] he
was doing but trump
it kind of got hacky with trump though
because it was so easy that it was like
every it's just like two it's like come
on
so trump's in the news again today
like i would see a bunch of memes about
trump i'm like all right dude like it's
i'm glad we don't have to see any more
things from him
yeah because it got so it was exhausting
it's exhausting it's just so worn out
trump was annoying as [ __ ] but the
people that hated trump were equally as
yeah
yeah and it was definitely just it's all
out the window so [ __ ] thank you
because the conversation was weird they
would say [ __ ] like can you believe it's
like yes i can believe it's been four
years he's been doing this and over
again like i believe that he's going to
do something this stupid
i was kind of surprised that he said
storm the capitol yeah yeah
a little bit i'm like wow what was your
favorite trump moment of uh
his presidency my favorite i said on the
podcast was when he forgot that his wife
was right next to him
that's pretty bad i wish melania sends
her best wishes
and she's like and she was in the jet
with him walked off the plane and she's
standing right next to him
a lot of you wishes uh sends her a best
wishes to you guys i'm like
she's sitting here what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
i'm right here did they say she was
going to try to run for president
that would have been dope no bro i heard
i thought i heard that was a thing i was
in hawaii so like
no idea she's a robot dude i don't even
think she's human yeah she might not be
she's your emotion you know why because
when you're married to trump you have to
kill all your emotions
i mean she for sure hates him oh yeah
there's so many clips of him trying to
hold her head
she's just like no walking like every
every press conference or something
anytime they're together there's always
that clip there's probably
thousands of those you could find
pictures of her breasts she has done
nude shoots amazing fantastic
bomb yeah and i think that should be a
new requirement for all first ladies
who's who's have you seen uh lord bush
favorite
favorite first lady laura who's yours
melania trump yeah overrated dude no
dude
obama michelle obama yeah she's she's
i love her podcast dude her podcast did
you have a good podcast yeah
it's it's a it's really well put
together and she kind of goes through
her personal life stories
specifically with obama like her being a
tomboy so she used to box
that's why i play football which you
could tell by her [ __ ] shoulders dude
yeah
that woman show there's our chat yeah
she's built bro
and they're just so likable michelle and
barack even though like forget all the
like the drone strikes and stuff like
that but besides that like
they're so likable yeah michelle obama
looked like she could [ __ ] you up though
she does look like she has hands like
your head or hand
they look heavy yes like they look dense
like i remember when i saw her i'm like
it looks like she knows how to check
calf kicks yeah yeah oh dude i was like
look at those [ __ ] shoulder pads dude
i was like why are she still wearing
that [ __ ] and like hot that's just her
shoulder
those are just dealt and i got him those
are dealt that's her shoulders and she
got them fangs on her dude you see those
[ __ ] michelle obama things
have you seen her teeth you got teeth
she got some sharp ass teeth i don't
notice her teeth no
look up one photo why are you just
looking at me
i was about to just agree just not to
sound dumb i'd be like yes yeah
they're totally great look at her
shoulders and her fangs she looks like
she'll [ __ ]
you up yeah she got some sick tries bro
like she got some good things
she looks like that they turn into a
human he looks crazy
i love michelle obama close-up right
here look at them teeth dude she got
them fangs she got some incisors bro
you tell me she won't bite the [ __ ] out
of an apple she do
she's like she'd be on true blood yeah
she would be like my favorite vampire
show
i love her dude her podcast is amazing
she had obviously she had barack on she
had her brother on but she went through
this whole
she was a tomboy she would play football
and then her dad wouldn't
treat her as if she was a girl she would
treat her as equal as one of the boys
but she would have to handle her own so
she learned how to box with her brothers
that's dope she got some hands football
i'm telling you she would [ __ ] somebody
up i put michelle obama versus melania
trump
she [ __ ] sucks her in her [ __ ]
melania
she looks frail looks like she needs to
drink some water too she just looks dry
all the time she's like
like high and tight you know yeah ashley
first lady dude i hate her guts
well let's talk about the topic today
because since he's been gone
two amazing things happen we'll talk
about first before we even talk about
conor mcgregor we have to talk about
the max holloway fight oh
that was probably my favorite fight i've
ever watched of all of all time like
i think performance wise just going into
the fight and like
the odds were stacked again even though
max was the favorite
everybody that watches mma was like yo
calvin cater
might [ __ ] this fool up because he has
hands and he's really good
and then max went out there and was like
oh yeah check this out
i'm gonna drop the ultimate [ __ ] like
he broke nine records on this dude's
[ __ ] face
yeah literally on his face and he's and
calvin kater's like legit like he's
[ __ ] really good yeah he's an animal
and we were sitting in and that that was
the day we came back we flew back to la
and we're i'm sitting in the uh airport
and i
watched the video and i was like man we
gotta hopefully we don't miss the fight
and i'm sitting in my luggage watching
it and your boy is like screaming
in the [ __ ] hollywood airport
everyone's looking at me like i'm crazy
but i'm like yo max holloway your guys's
guy
is fighting but nobody really gave a
[ __ ] wow it's crazy
how fast max is dude like he just he was
so
[ __ ] quick and i i think she was the
timing his timing was
great he was beating him he just
couldn't touch him like calvin
i mean he hit him with a few stuff but
that's just because max was going crazy
yeah but other than that man like max
was rolling a lot of his punches just
come back he always hit him with the jab
jab cross yeah
the most basic i've never hit that
sparring ever
not yet well you shitty ass coach
david we gotta do more jab jab cross
dude but his setups were nice his faints
were
nice i mean tell me tell me what strike
he didn't do you know what i mean
oblique kick half kick body kick back
kick
uh head kick spinning head elbows elbow
a couple of fat elbows that rocked
out of him he was like a video game
character bro like he was hitting him
somebody was
like smashing the buttons yeah he was
doing this smashing all the buttons yeah
that was unfucking believable he hit the
record for what the most
strikes done in the main event or just
in general i think in general just in a
fight
he has the top he has top three he has
calvin kater he broke the record with
calvin kater
he broke the record with brian ortega
that's number two and number three is
the one against dustin poyer so he bro
he has all top three records of most
significant strikes landing in a fight
bro how the [ __ ] did calvin cater
survive yeah
five rounds of the of like that was like
a cia torture session
ass beating bro that was like that was
like where are the documents
because yeah bro like we're trying to
find osama level
what the [ __ ] bro did he kidnap your
children like what did he do to you yeah
he gave him a navy seal
team six ass yeah what round was it
round two or round three where he ended
it with that head kick that almost
knocked him out i think that was round
three that he
well first he held him twice right
before that's right so his elbow rocked
elbow rocked again head kick rocked
again and then the end of the round and
then he has the [ __ ] chicken legs
and then somehow he survived for the
what the third or fourth round yeah
he got elbowed like 80 times in the face
dude
unbelievable i felt so bad for him at
the fifth round he's like i'm the best
boxer like the dopest [ __ ] you could
ever
like that was literally the that was the
coolest moment
i have ever watched live in a fight like
i just was like oh my god i can't
believe he's doing this i remember when
he was started doing it dan hardy was
like commentating and just
as he started screaming dan hardy just
started going
he was coming in his pants because they
can't believe what they're watching he
was standing
he was literally running around the
[ __ ] arena that dan hardy was he was
standing the whole time like oh my god
dude that he was flipping
that was a god mode level performance
like that was
yeah the cool [ __ ] the the best of the
best and also max holloway is the champ
like that's the thing too i think that
because caterer is really good but a lot
of people i think thought it was going
to be closer than
like we're kind of not discrediting max
holloway but kind of forgetting how good
he was is because he technically lost a
lot
like on paper loss last match or
whatever but realistically i think he
beat volkonovsky that dude's the champ
in my eyes like nobody nobody agrees
that volkonowski won that fight except
for people in bolkanovsky's camp
sure right other than that everybody
says max one so
so it's a weird thing even volkanovsky
knows like you
know you [ __ ] i love you don't don't
ever fight me but
you know you know you lost yeah he's
kind of a cornball anyway though no i
like him i actually like the doganovsky
yeah he seems cool all right why don't
you go marry him then
i got you
why don't you go marry the guy yeah
what's wrong daddy like get the [ __ ] out
get out here before i beat you
and that's warranty that's warranty yeah
yeah it was amazing because
he did max did everything that i wanted
him to do in his previous fight
which is open up with his [ __ ] legs
his kicks are so
good and it's just it's so much easier
if you train at all you know this
it's so much easier when you're sparring
with somebody and they're only throwing
just boxing yeah and you get kicked and
you can punch and you do all this other
[ __ ]
it's so much easier to deal with if
someone's just boxing but now
max is finally starting to use more of
his weapons which i feel like he's
always had but he just kind of fell in
love with boxing for a while
and it just shows because you look at
calvin keator's variety
didn't really throw that much writing
and i think what he was wanting to
happen or what he planned on
happening was they would exchange in
these boxing
exchanges and he would crack him and he
like you would say
calvin kater has the power advantage
yeah over max holloway of course and he
was hoping that like oh
if i crack him a couple times like he's
going to feel it because that's what
usually happens when people fight calvin
right
he cracks them enough he gets hit a lot
but he cracks him enough where
he hurts them and then he takes over hey
unless calvin keator hits his heart as
dustin poirier
nothing was going to happen yeah yeah i
mean because he got hit by pourier bombs
and he didn't even have chicken like
that for five rounds
yeah yeah yeah he's got a [ __ ] chin
on him
but dude i remember at one point he did
a like he did a jab up top
jab downstairs right hand and then he he
like
did the jab upstairs fainted it
downstairs and then spinning back kicked
right after and i was like oh my god i
did that five more times
and hit him with like eight spinning
back kicks like across the [ __ ] ring
like dragon ball z [ __ ] when they would
go into the rocks
like that like breaking through every
building yeah
i was surprised how well his body was
holding up to those body shots
like he was eating a hundred body shots
when he was pressed against the cage
because max kept uh switching it up
elbow elbow but when he saw the body
open
i'm like fall down already yeah just
give it up bro i was surprised the ref
didn't stop the fight
yeah yeah i mean yeah well because he
was still i think i think the corner
should be yeah that's what i was gonna
say
it's like a corner move because he was
definitely coherent enough to keep
fighting
but especially going from the fourth
round to the fifth round the corner
should have been like
nah bro i mean what is this what what
would cater do
like what what what could he have done
in that case differently because i think
he just had to
like he was too stationary he kept
circling to like max's powerslide
over and over he kept circling to his
right side that's why he got head kicked
twice
yep that's the right foot that beautiful
slip to the head kick
oh my right hand was just like he was
running to his right hand a lot
but not just that but just max was just
overwhelming him i just think i think
yeah i think he was outgunned yeah i
think he needed this experience to learn
like i need more tools and i need to i
need to like reset like how brian ortega
evolved and then bought korean zombie
like way better
uh i think that's like this moment for
cater too but holloway's like the
teacher dude he's literally like
teaching
when he fought brian ortega which also
when i saw the brian ortega fight i was
like this is the coolest [ __ ]
ever and i don't think anyone could ever
top this performance
and he did with colin cater so that's
crazy unbelievable but in the middle of
the bryan ortega fight
he puts his he takes brianna take his
hands puts him on his head and he's like
this is how you block hooks and threw a
hook and he blocked it he's like yeah
see there you go
in the middle of the fight max holloway
did that that's unbelievable how really
[ __ ] defeating is that dude i would
just leave i know i'm already
like for me i'm out yeah i'm like i'm
going it's called timeout
i said hey i'm done guys but it's even
crazier that brian ortega was like all
right i'm gonna take some time off and
he came back even better
which is dope but he definitely
shouldn't have shaved his head yeah
yeah hideous without his hair he looks
like a crazy guy has no idea
unbelievable
unbelievable unbelievable i'm
unbelievable
he did a really good job of making the
fight boring
yeah like he he did it first one even
the second one like he tried to mitigate
as much as he could and
disengaging yeah like he didn't allow
max to tee off because and that's what
like dustin did
like pretty well too also with the power
shots as well but like
he like max holloway would he needs to
get momentum
and volkanovsky didn't allow him to get
that momentum he would circle away he'd
move his feet a lot
and for the most part calvin kater was
stationary and then every time max would
push him back
he'd be moving back on his back foot and
then he had no answer for max house
that jab jab crossed exactly he just
backing him up and he was just
shelling up also too with volkonovsky
it's it's just the threat of the
takedown
definitely changes things up things like
the kicks the low kicks right
hater cater never he was never worried
about a takedown coming from cater so he
was free to just be like
[ __ ] it you know but if so maybe if
cater would have shot on him a little
bit and kind of gave him something to
worry about gave him something to worry
about it would be nice
yeah he's just his hands you know right
because he plants and throws that's his
thing i was watching his previous fights
because alex is a huge fan of cater
and caterer does get hit he gets hit a
lot actually but then because we
but when he plants and he strikes he
cracks people hard yeah and i think when
he couldn't do that to max he's like
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah right constantly
floating his head off the center line
and then apparently max was saying that
for the break their game plan going into
the fight was oh his significant strikes
absorbed
is really high so max was like i'm sure
to keep hitting him
until he goes down that was his game
plan that's [ __ ] crazy
insane also holloway's conditioning bro
how the [ __ ] is that
your output so he looked just as good in
his fifth round
yeah his first round and in in the press
conference he said he was getting tired
and i was it did not look like it
yeah at all in the second volkanovsky
fight you could say
that the reason why people maybe gave
the fight to bolkanovsky is because in
the fourth and fifth round his output
like got diminished yeah and he looked
like he got tired
but if he were to keep that pace up and
i think he probably would have won that
fight decisively
yeah and it allowed volkanovsky to kind
of come back in because he he did slow
down a little bit well didn't
volkanovsky also land a couple takedowns
in the last couple rounds in the fifth
round he laughed he landed a big one and
held him down i guess that was
that was like people kind of give too
much credit to take down i don't think
takedown should be giving credit to any
fighter unless they do something with it
exactly
i agree that's that goes back to the
henry cejudo fight
with mighty mouse and that's what
happened right it's like at the end of
the round hold him down and the fight's
over oh but you're on your knees and
you got held down for the last fight so
every time he shot and he tried to take
down mighty mouse he he reversed it yeah
rolling and
they considered that a take are you
[ __ ] kidding me yeah that's what i
think it makes no sense yeah
it was masterful what he was doing yeah
and so that's why even with henry cejudo
he has that asterisk
like ah did you really beat him though
yeah i'm not sure and now volkonoski has
to deal with that
yeah right [ __ ] him we'll see we'll see
we'll see what happens when he fights
ortega
i'm very curious to see how that goes
that's actually i mean it would be cool
if ortega beats him
oh and then [ __ ] he just stirs has to
fight max again
i almost want ortega to lose so he could
fight cater i want ortega ortega and
cater to fight two people that [ __ ]
max gold
let's see you guys duke it out yeah yeah
see what happens that would be dope
also i wouldn't be mad if i mean i know
holloway is still in the 145 mix right
now but if
like that hallway fighting poirier again
like or one of the 150 fighters would be
would be sick to see too yeah i mean
even when he fought poorly and he lost
he still
almost finished poijay what do you have
times yeah he was watching a couple
times
he had him in the anaconda choke which
was right bro
it was done that was it and just like
you said does the point was like hey
you got me you would have got me sauce
and he gave it to us
enjoy this yeah yeah but yeah man i'm
just really curious to see
i i just feel bad for calvin kater too
because he's such a hot prospect
and i just want him to like recover
because that dude that's a career ender
type aspect yeah like
like but so was ortega's and ortega
actually looks sorry i beat that record
even more like that was even more
one-sided than brian ortega yeah
like and i couldn't possibly thought how
would that ever be a thing like
who could top that how one-sided of a
beat down
brian ortega max hollywood yeah that was
unbelievable and then he fought
complicated was like oh yeah check this
out
i'm even better than that boxer in the
ufc yeah the freshman came to play when
he started screaming that i just i was
out of my stuff
i'm like you know what the [ __ ] but but
say but but saying in a ufc fight that
like and you guys are
30 years old and he's like i'm going to
show you who the real freshman is like
that
kind of like come on bro that's a that's
calvin kidder you know he's
really bad he doesn't really talk it's
not his thing don't don't do it yeah and
he tried he saw one bisping video
and he was like i'm gonna try this out
i'm a tree like a freshman
wait what was that count did you say
that to the mic i'm seriously a
fisherman
wait what i'm so what are we saying i'm
a tree
oh okay okay yeah it's it works and then
max is like
what uh-huh who what a loser i'm gonna
beat this guy up
what the [ __ ] i'm gonna take this one
what if he was like i'm just gonna like
[ __ ] him up a little bit but then he
heard that line was like oh i'm gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of this fool yeah that
was the line that pushed him over i
think he kind of did because i think i
missed him
he kept mentioning it yeah he kept
saying it in like multiple interviews i
was like oh [ __ ] that really
was so funny that's your skin people
forget that these new prospects that are
coming out
are older than max he's 29.
and he's like double their fights yeah
he's turning 30 this year he's still in
his prime habib was like he's not even
in his prime yet
yeah isn't that crazy and he's like i
think he could be the greatest
the goat saying that max hallway could
be the goat i don't know it's hard to
see
somebody be better than habib though
it's really hard such an animal bro if
he comes back
i don't even want to see him come back
now now i'm just like i want to see
i got to see who's going to be his
challenge now i'm just like ah there's
nobody
like just let just stay retired it's got
to be a gaichi style
chandler fight like that wrestler
hard-hitting wrestler
that's actually he might come back for
chandler if chandler just starts wiping
out the division yeah he'll be like oh
this is a new challenge
yeah maybe but i think for habib because
his that father passed away and his
father was the head coach of his giant
dagestani eagles mma team i think he
just fit right into that role he's like
just take over his head yeah because
it's
to him it's like dc was talking about
after the gaechi fight he said i talked
to him that night
and he didn't really talk about the
fight at all all he was saying was like
all right how do we get
islam his teammate how did we get umar
his teammate how do we get
us man his other teammate how do we get
these guys better really in that
coaching role yeah like how do we get um
duron win all these guys from aka how do
we get these guys
better and how do we get them to charge
i'll tell you how to get the ron win
better lose some [ __ ] weight dude
[ __ ]
was like definitely not in his weight
class he a thick boy he could lose some
[ __ ] weight
you better not hear he was he was
yelling at some people in an interview
about it
so he's going to come beat your ass tell
him what's he going to do beat me up
i was like oh
wrestle me or something he's like one of
the wrestling coaches he teaches
everybody how to wrestle at aka
he's a [ __ ] beast that guy damn dude
but he
i mean his fights are so shitty though
like he's not he's not putting it well i
haven't seen his last fight
he won but his previous fight was
terrible like he's he's a pure wrestler
wrestler
but he doesn't put it together like dc
does so it's like it's hard and i feel
like for him
he's vastly undersized for that weight
class
yeah he's really small because 185 if
it's 170 yeah maybe
170 but he 170 is like dc being at 205
which makes sense for me but him at 185
he looks
that's gonna be an adjustment though
yeah because he's pro he probably just
walks around like that anyway like he
probably doesn't cut down he's not
cutting weight for sure
a hundred percent but some dudes they're
just
they're just so built differently you
know like they're just their frame like
alex
you telling me that [ __ ] could
fight out 185 yeah it's going to take
some years
like alex like 280.
he's trying to lose some weight so i
think i think he's going to be able to
he's he's going to probably
be able to hit like when he look when
you see him at 220 he looks pretty lean
yeah very muscular at 220. so it's like
you'll probably
be lower what's gonna happen right you
think you reach 205
i think he can i don't know i saw a
picture of him at 205. you see his bones
bro
he got some thick-ass bones he's thick
he's wolverine bro yeah he's
a he's made out of metal that guy hey
alex if you're watching this
grow back your facial hair yeah that
means you come back
yeah i say [ __ ] these fools you rock it
without it alex you look like a straight
uncircumcised penis
that's just crazy like i i just i miss
the facial hair yeah the facial hair
i miss it so much it looks like a giant
cute baby a real handsome strong yeah it
looks like a big old big old baby
that'll [ __ ] strangle you to death
yeah that's exactly what gorilla hands
that is crazy well let's talk
about for you if you guys aren't fight
fans these are fights that you guys
should watch like yeah the next hallway
fight is one of those things that even
if you don't like fighting
you'll be amazed at what you just
witnessed and it was on abc
which is even cooler yeah but i don't
think people appreciated it enough but i
don't know
yeah but we watch the uh everybody knows
who conor mcgregor is
there are people who i know do not watch
mma and they bought the pay-per-view to
watch conor mcgregor fight
yeah mcgregor is like a superstar
transcended the sport yeah
like crazy everyone knows that guy's
name he's a he's a household name he
really is a good thing for mma though i
mean i know the [ __ ] talking and whatnot
might not be good but like in terms of
talking with dope popularity and whatnot
he brought a lot of exposure to
a hundred percent he was so good at it
though he was so funny it's like he was
[ __ ] talking
who the [ __ ] is that yeah every time i
watch it i just snicker and the whole
time jeremy stevens is like yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] it i'll knock you out
leprechaun you know what good one
anyway and he just goes off and he's
just like he had nothing for him you
know what though i saw a tweet where
jeremy stephens was with conor
mcgregor's mom and they took a picture
in like a casino or something and
they're like holding each other
and he wrote your mom knows who the [ __ ]
i am
which was like so solid it was like six
years later but it was still like damn
this is great
that's funny there was another like i
think in an interview
somebody was like so do you know do you
did you really not know who jeremy
stevens was and he goes
of course i knew who he was that was
just a funny thing to say yeah you know
and i'm like ass tight
people are idiots bro the journalists
and stuff it's like obviously part of
this he's talking [ __ ]
he's on the stage with him he's gonna
say wild [ __ ] what the [ __ ] doesn't know
who jeremy stephen is
if you're in the ufc the guy's an animal
yeah right
he's probably matched up with him at
some point you know like come on jeremy
stevens is one of those dude that
loses but nobody wants to fight him yeah
right because it's too scary he's
i met him i met him in person he's a
[ __ ] he's an intense dude he's one of
those i just i will
always watch a jeremy stephens fight no
matter what oh yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
if you like this boy scraps yeah he
comes for a calvin keator knocked him
the [ __ ] out that was a great
that was crazy dude jeremy stephens was
doing great yeah yeah he was giving him
some [ __ ] trouble broke his [ __ ]
nose
yeah and calvin cannon breaks his nose
all the time
like yeah that was kendra's first like
real test i feel like this hallway
though like was like such a jump up in
competition though but then again like
two it's like yeah it's leaving a little
earlier
dude for calvin kater i really do think
like that dude is gonna be
like if it wasn't i feel like he could
beat bokonovsky and i feel like he could
beat ortega i feel like he's second
like he has the potential to be the next
champ if max wasn't there
about oliveira though yeah well he had
55 now
oh that's right huh he down at 155. he
won 55 now oliveira
yeah oh yeah that's right dude oliver
look good 155 is definitely his weight
then because he's
smashing dude that's a good fight
and he got some dope glasses too have
you ever seen glasses yeah you said i
never saw his last one
he looks like a reading lesson tony
ferguson if you never did crack or
something like that yeah
like a very clean sane tony ferguson
yeah exactly
he's pretty amazing but yeah conor
mcgregor if you guys watch the fight i
mean everybody obviously loves him but
he got his ass
knocked the [ __ ] out there was a lot of
sad people that night and a lot of happy
people that night i was very sad
yeah that was also sad i was bummed just
weird watching him not do the same stuff
that he normally does yeah different
stance planted his feet wasn't moving
no oblique kicks no side kicks no front
kicks what the [ __ ]
i just felt like it was international
yeah it was it was a disservice
to his actual skill set yeah if nobody
has ever seen him fight before you would
be ver you would have been very
disappointed yeah
because that's not him that's not how he
fights and i feel like the fight had the
potential to be like
very competitive and a really good fight
like i didn't want to see any of those
guys yet like finish really early i
wanted to see like a five round i mean
he rocked dustin like
a couple times in that first round hard
hard like he had the chicken leg that's
the thing is i
i think it was competitive up until it
wasn't right but
but it just seemed it was it it was
trending like oh [ __ ] this is
crazy and then it well obviously if
you're a
connor fan it was kind of anti-climactic
so that's probably where
i'm feeling sad i mean it was it wasn't
the result you wanted to see
but it was still like that was still
sick i mean it was it was a good fight i
mean
even right before then conor was still
pressing him up against it literally
changed in one second and within that
change 15 seconds later it was over
he made the adjustment to the calf kicks
a little too late because he was
catching them yeah catching him throwing
down it right down the pipe
right but then it was too late by then
his leg was already [ __ ] so that's the
problem though with calf kicks is like
you could take like low kicks to the
quad all day like if you catch that
yeah right at that level you know at
that level you can catch those
you can catch those kicks and throw at
the same time but the if it makes
contact to your shin
or your calf it still [ __ ] hurts no
matter if you catch it anyway like
it's still colliding against your leg
before you catch it so it's like
he did wasn't doing what he needed to do
such thing as calf conditioning
yeah right what do you do hit it with a
broomstick
and that's it yeah that's you just have
to deal with it yeah i'm surprised like
how uh prevalent it is in the ufc right
now
yeah and you know when we were when we
were training uh the last time we
kickbox
it's it's definitely a lot more readily
available that calf kick unless
somebody checks it then you're [ __ ]
because you can break your foot pretty
easy
but it's it's just right there you can
just whip it fast the angle is different
too
yeah you know i've actually never
experienced them like
fully like that i've never got a full
cap they [ __ ] honestly on accident
kick but
never like where someone was targeting
it i don't know i mean i know
like the thigh hurts like a [ __ ]
in and of itself you can't take too many
of those either
but the calf would be interesting i
don't know how apparently i mean you see
everybody
like to demonstrate yeah come on please
because it's me
it's not just the calf but it's the the
muscle on the side right next to the
shin and the anterior tibialis
and that one's it's a small muscle and
it's like you ever tried rolling it out
it's like
oh that [ __ ] hurts is that so it's a
really small like thin
narrow muscle so you can't condition
that do you feel like conor mcgregor is
going to be competitive from here on out
because i feel like i don't see it in
him anymore
i don't know i go back and forth i'm
back and forth too i'm undecided because
one a
w like if he wasn't like why why would
he have
come back at all you know i mean he he
literally doesn't have to
at all yeah you know and he did seem
when he was in the mix like
he was there to get it like it wasn't
like he was yeah yeah i see that
you know uh but he i
to me it seemed like he just really be
i think his problem was he one foot in
one door and one foot in the other right
so his eyes were still on a possible
matchup with pacquiao and whatnot
yeah i think he just fell in love with
his [ __ ] boxing and he probably want
to showcase
part of it yeah part of it was that he
potentially could fight pacquiao
or canelo or somebody i mean and you
look at it from hindsight his boxing was
better than poryus except for that last
flurry it was he was hitting with that
jab like a [ __ ] yeah right and
then he started getting careless and
then he started heading up henton
head hunting too much yeah and that i
think that ultimately led to his
downfall
yeah but but the first round i was
watching i was like bro where's his
kicks yeah
wait what's going on that's what made
him good that's what made him great was
his kicks his his variety
because when you have somebody throwing
crazy [ __ ] at you
that's just kind of like a decoy and
then you have a killer [ __ ] left hand
that's hard to deal with what's the name
of the game in any combat it's just make
somebody think about this and then you
hit them with this exactly
so the more tools you possess whether
it's a shot or kicks
whatever you get him thinking about this
and then you can hit him with this
that's what made him so successful
before and he was doing literally none
of that
and he was so heavy in his stance yeah
um which is completely unlike him
so light normally yes bouncing pop pop
he's very karate
yeah so heavy so i think he just fought
him wrong yeah and
and obviously [ __ ] paid the price for
it but people people were writing in the
comments they were like yeah
he's so much more turned out i [ __ ] his
maturity go
back to the original conor mcgregor he
needs to be a crazy person i'm gonna
come out the lake like a leviathan
and swallow you up like a phoenix out of
flames like
i don't know what that means
you're gonna knock somebody out that
full says some ridiculous [ __ ] and all
this
he didn't say any of that stuff yeah no
no promotion like that i'll snatch it
like an eagle from a
from a wicker basket off in england like
the [ __ ] bro
you're risking it the detail the wicker
i see you just laying down to like me
pray
yeah [ __ ] goat with your belly open
i'll slice you open and eat your innards
boy
boy boy and but they they're
they have odds for the rematch and he's
the favorite he's still the favorite
i saw that yeah he got his ass beat like
that yeah people sleep on dustin poirier
huh
yeah they really do boy is a [ __ ]
animal dude
disrespect hasn't lost him for i think
what was it four years the only loss
he's had is kabi
which is like a given yeah like come on
everyone loses
he fought him in abu dhabi which is like
like home town for
habib and he just smashed him out and it
was probably one of the more like
one-sided fights that habib has had yeah
against a guy that's that good
yeah jorge is a [ __ ] animal though
bro people really do sleep on him
he beat gaichi he beat everybody yeah i
think he only hasn't fought
uh ferguson and diaz i think is the only
ones he has bought but i think
i think he beats both of them i want him
ideas he was like i want to beat that
for his [ __ ] ass that's what he was
saying
he's like saucy ass [ __ ] dustin poyo
yeah
yeah i know you know because before he
was the guy that would talk that would
fight anybody
but now he's just fighting nobody so
he's just i don't care anymore dude like
he literally could care less especially
after maz vidal beat the brakes off of
him his last win was what anthony pettis
yeah was it yeah that was anthony pettis
and then he fought maz vidal
oh [ __ ] dude i want to see mozzarella
kobe covington can we get that [ __ ]
going i heard that i heard they're gonna
do
uh the ultimate fighter with them oh
that's awesome wow
that's still doing the ultimate fighter
yeah yeah people could say whatever they
want about kobe covington he's a dope
fighter
yeah he's a beast hey what do you think
his new stick is going to be now he's
still riding the trump train
i saw him like pissed about mark goddard
he said he doesn't like republicans he
was like four brexit or against brexit
he's like still on the republican now
it's from trump to republicans
remember where did that [ __ ] go dude
just fight just fight you're good
you're good we know yeah you got the
exposure [ __ ] it
take off the hat you feel okay it would
be tight if he was just like yeah i was
just [ __ ] with you guys all the time
like let's go let's fight yeah that
would be cool cozy covington looks like
he's gonna get skin cancer tomorrow
he just got that look on him it looks
like a clone dude yeah someone made him
an elaborate
exactly like like agent 47 from hitman
or some [ __ ]
military clone right yeah he looks weird
as [ __ ] yeah that's so funny yeah
he looks like if you took a the helmet
off a storm trooper it would be his face
yeah
they're just like cloned like like the
color of his lips is all ashy
yeah his face looks ashy i'm like you're
not a human being dude
everybody compares them to the the kid
from toy story you know what that was
yeah
yeah he does look like sick yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] short spiky hair bro i was
like yeah i'll fight you too
yeah colby just kidding he seems like a
nice guy though
yeah he seems chill he seems like a real
life guy
i'll beat you up guy dragon energy what
is that from
he said i talked about that oh dude what
are you talking about handled that
interview so well dude tomorrow is a g
but what are you talking about
well kobe covington was like when he
hurt him when he shook trump's hand he
felt dragon energy
and i was like whoa what is that mean
bro
he said he felt drag dragon energy and
the only thing i could think of
is like some kkk
like you know what he last time in
carmaro i broke your
face yeah i broke your jaw guys it's a
matter of fact he goes i
broke your face so it was like the
funniest [ __ ] interview ever dude
because
like kamar wasn't mad he was just like
he's laughing
he's laughing and that's when he's at
his best tomorrow's just like laughs
like y'all dude like
this guy's a [ __ ] clown and he's just
he's not doing this thing where he
he talks like a sexy cool guy uh at the
end of the day
yeah right you know i'm out here just
trying to be the best and i'm trying to
be a champion you know what i mean yeah
yeah it's like cut that out dude yeah
stop being a sexy
bro because i'm taking my shirt off
that's why that's why [ __ ] tyler
woodley was cracking jokes at him he's
like people trying to sound like a
little cool j like relax
man like chill with that [ __ ] whisper
[ __ ]
i'll fight you too i'll fight everyone
this is what david challenges everybody
possibly i drink a little too much
i'll fight everybody you know who does
that is sometimes i'll be like i follow
dustin poyo on instagram right
and i'll scroll through and then usually
when someone you follow like comments on
it you could see it yeah
and what do i see bark quan fight me you
[ __ ]
and then he goes on like colby
covington's like uh you're a [ __ ]
bart yeah like just he just does i don't
watch trolling
i'll be like hey bro do you remember
doing this he goes nah
i'll be like bart so bart's just trying
to give them to barbell gear yeah
yeah yeah i sent you some stuff actually
now that i have your attention
yeah can i send you some barbell and
there's something to it there's
something to
his you know there's a method to his
madness that's just [ __ ]
dude the one of the funny have you did
you see that story that gio put up
so let me tell you something i have not
laughed that hard
in a very long time was it today this
was a couple of days ago
they have the security cam in front of
their house so oh bro
bart and tyga are playing uh like
foursquare or catch with the four square
ball
taika throws the ball taika is bart's
son by the way throws the ball and for
and when in the camera it looks like a
neighborhood kid
but it's just it's actually bart bart
has a ball and for some reason this full
thought
he should slam the ball to the floor but
keep his face in front of it
pull four smacks right in the face and
he just goes oh
[ __ ] his face was this close off the
ground
like he literally bent over so far like
and he and his smash is
as hard as possible this is a power
lifter by the way
and it's not a medicine ball you know
medicine ball when he's dropping it it
just slams to the floor
yeah this dude it's a it's a square ball
yeah it's a bouncy ass ball you could
slam it to the ground it'll go to the
[ __ ] [ __ ] three-year-old
it finally has the contract so he's
actually going to fight jake paul i'm
actually kind of worried
for ben what are the best descriptions
of
ben askren fighting they said that ben
askren strikes like he's looking for a
light switch in the dark
his hands out like dude which is highly
accurate
yeah yeah he's like a mummy bro he's
like he he literally comes at you like a
[ __ ] mummy hands
stiff as [ __ ] so like dude this is a
funny video of
he did a sponsorship with like a
kickboxing bag oh yeah i watched that
this morning it was it was a bellator ad
for everlast
out of all the people you could get to
hit a kickboxing bag you picked ben
askren you guys have douglas lima yeah
yeah like a legit [ __ ]
kickboxing guy and they get ben askred
and he's just like
it was really bad and but i don't
understand too
i know ben askren's uh wrestling is
really dope jake paul might be a genius
bro
maybe he might be a [ __ ] genius
because for him to like obviously he was
hitting all these people up just to
create like
clout and sure yeah which is the problem
with you know well he knows that these
fighters just want the paycheck yeah
they're like oh
i'll make what he's dangling carrots in
front of people let's do it give me the
15 10 million i'll do it to fight this
[ __ ] yeah who do you think wins
aspen or paul if you had to like if you
had a bet
whereas like you must bet like your
house on this this is what i think is
gonna happen
i think a bit i feel like ben askren is
smart
for the most part you know and i feel
like he's gonna dirty box with him and
just clinch them up
and just make it real ugly and just make
it a real boring fight
and maybe he could just you know and he
has a lot obviously way more experience
he's fought in three different
promotions he's
fought way tougher guys yeah with way
more you know weapons at his disposal
but there's still a chance that jake
paul is going to just piece this
because if he loses to jake paul i will
go over to [ __ ] ben ashmore's house
and [ __ ] in front of his door
i would be so pissed today yeah because
you know you know i i was watching the
aerial hawaii
uh interview with ben askren and he was
saying that listen i'm a
fighter i fought killers in this ring
but
it wasn't straight boxing and that's
something that you almost have zero
experience in yeah right like
legit just watching his boxing it's
terrible he got it yeah
everybody he fought yeah he got out
struck by [ __ ] what's his name
damian maya he made him look like a
[ __ ] boxing champion that guy
so what is he gonna do but it is a
different sport right because everything
he does
in mma is to set up for the takedown
because his wrestling is that [ __ ]
good i gotta think that the experience
and just the because jake paul
confidence your confidence and the fact
that
ascertain is a real fighter like a real
real fighter
he competed in the olympics it kind of
just depends on the ref
i think how much the ref allows yeah if
the ref quickly breaks them up
then asprin i think is in for a long
night because but if if he allows him to
work a little bit dirty box like you
said i think astrid definitely takes it
and the thing with jake paul is that we
haven't seen him compete against
a fighter or somebody in the same weight
class exactly like he's fighting
guys that are you know youtube
celebrities
zero boxing experience and i feel like
for a guy like nate robinson
if he had just the proper coaches and
the proper like
you know training going hard at least
once yeah
exactly the fact that he didn't spar is
crazy but like
i feel like with that even being said
hey robinson did kind of pretty good for
not being able to spar
oh 100 didn't do that he did pretty good
they did and
for three months of training he's and
jake paul's not like
from what i've seen in my analysis he's
not really that big of a puncher like
yeah i feel like ben asker has been
punched by a
better dude yes 100 and he has a chin
robbie lawler yeah
chin but it's a boxing only fight
and that makes me very nervous he has a
[ __ ] up hip
he just got a replacement he says he
feels better than ever okay well
we'll [ __ ] it then all right ben asked
me all the way i hope dude yeah i hope i
hope
but there's still a chance god damn it
yeah
please imagine if jake paul wins dude
it'd be embarrassing it'd be really
embarrassing there's gonna be so many
ben asking memes dude there was already
bad first bad
if he gets knocked out by jake paul it's
gonna be worse than he got needed and
jake paul is trying hard
he's training an american top team i
think oh really
jake he's trying to he's training with
jorge he moved to florida he's moving
he's training with like jorge
and all this guy really he's gonna calf
kick him and [ __ ]
wow what the [ __ ] so that's the other
thing though too it's like you have
money dude you could literally do
whatever
yeah what the [ __ ] yeah damn i need to
go find a real coach
that teaches me how to really fight his
name is mike brown and he trains an
american top team
no i refuse dude training actually
requires me to work and i don't have the
time for that
i need to get some knees first david so
i'm using kneecaps man let me tell you
something guys if you guys don't have
knees
training is really hard it's yeah
walking is hard
walking is hard anything hard i can't
jog i can't do nothing
are you trying to jog anywhere bro i
just missed the fact that i could jump
um hey baby
how about you're just buying some time i
just see people jogging i'm like
i wish i could do that and then you do
it and you're like ah [ __ ] this [ __ ]
yeah
that's not that it could be fun it's not
it's never fun
when is it fun to jog it sucks i like
walking insane
why people do it it looks like they're
having the time of their life dude
they'd be [ __ ] jogging through
highland park and [ __ ]
yeah they do yeah but it's like what's
their life like
gotta be miserable they're just trying
to get away from their wife
they're just getting staying out of the
house enough to go back like all that
runner high [ __ ] i've never felt that in
my life i've ran enough to have runner's
high
never i felt you is that i don't know
because every time i'm done running i'm
like [ __ ] that sucked ass
i don't feel good i feel light-headed
and weird but it's not a good feeling
they're like do you reach a point where
you hit this high and i'm like
this is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard in my life it's all about
mentality going into it you know like if
they
if they sold that feeling in a bottle
for me to drink i would never drink that
[ __ ] in my life i throw it out the
[ __ ] way the company's going under
it doesn't feel good i feel weird but i
don't like it
you know the feeling you get after you
spar with somebody you know yeah
and you was like man that was dope
that's that feeling but for
relative to somebody that only runs
because for most people
when they run that's their only outlet
and they don't do any other sort of
exercise
so for them it's like oh this feels
great but if they were to do
literally anything else maybe they'd
probably feel the same
exact way how do you do you know those
uh the body conditioning does that stuff
really work
the body condition would probably just
get sucked in the gut too i don't think
so no
okay i think i think so i think i don't
know yeah i think there's something to
it you think something you're getting
stocked in the stomach yeah
definitely like it builds abs like
you're saying abs like abs
but like but teaching your body how to
absorb
impact that is relative so when they
just line you up and they just start
when they punch your face no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
yeah that's that's that's
you can condition your chin i don't know
what you're talking about yeah just slam
in on a [ __ ]
sometimes i just wait for people to ride
their bikes so i could walk in front of
it and then put my chin right there
david got knocked out again today yeah
his nose is on the other side of his
face
easy stuff dude yeah actually my face is
in this round it's just swollen
in the face all the time he's actually
really thin he just slams his face
looks great right now you have no idea
you don't look swollen at all yeah i
think something
his face is always in flame from getting
punched by patrick riley manny pacquiao
yes is that confirmed that's confirmed
dude but it's an
exhibition match i heard oh yeah i just
heard that today i don't know i don't
know why
they're professionals pro fighters yeah
pacquiao is still fighting like i know i
don't i'm not retired
i don't i directed i'm pretty sure it's
an exhibition match i got patrick
stupid i got i got pacquiao too i got
pacquiao
he just beat keith thurman yeah yeah
that guy's legit how long ago was that
because pacquiao is a little on the
older side that was uh
i think last year in his 40s he's 41. is
he in his 40s
i think so he's a senator bro what kind
of political aspirations does ryan
garcia have yeah
true that what a singer you know for
somebody who says that he never gets
porn star ryan garcia talks like he has
cte
yeah i'm like i'm not as a joke he
literally just sounds like he has some
cte when he talks i'm like does he
he slurs his words a little bit a lot
yeah yeah so but he says like he
he never gets hit so he's like young
though huh maybe you shouldn't say that
because now you just sound stupid
bro when he got hit by luke campbell he
got dropped i was like i thought i was
surprised he got up me too
like the way he crumbled and felt like
he he was he was out when he hit the mat
but the fact that he came back and like
beat him afterwards
was [ __ ] money dude picture perfect
the body of the body shot the body yeah
yeah nuts he's such a pretty boy though
he really is he's such a
like he he's he's more of a pretty boy
than oscar de la hoya and super mega
christian i saw him getting baptized in
the river or something yeah yeah yeah
or something like a christian i saw a
video of him getting somebody dunking
him in water and talking about jesus and
i was like i turned it off i was like
that's enough for me
thank you that's all i'll have you know
what's so weird about these fighters
they when they go into the ring they're
like first of all before i want to say
anything else
i want to thank god for helping smash
this guy's teeth in
like literally murdering me but i feel
like i think
i think for some guys they need that
going in they need that like
that faith going because fighting in
general is very
obviously scary as [ __ ] yeah so any sort
of like
extras like i don't know what the word
is like any affinity
yeah faith and like more peace of mind
to help you like
destinies yes like i feel like that
really does help i'm almost
sure you've got to bring god in it dude
you know god don't condone this [ __ ]
yeah please god let me break this
motherfucker's nose
he's like unless benjamins then he could
do it all you want my baby like all
these like thugs are doing that yo
please god when i [ __ ] spray this
house up god i got that
i hope i hit at least a wife and a
husband
in the name of your name i pray it's a
random bystander
if i hit a baby please send me to heaven
and then god's like you did it you hit a
baby yo that's a dope track
if i hit a baby please send me the
heaven
i'm loving it mcdonald's and that's
their new ad yeah it's a new ad campaign
from mcdonald's
we're trying to sell the senate box did
you ever thank god
no did they ever give you like a mic to
say something after you fight bro
they're like get the [ __ ] out for that
they never give you a mic
ah bro did anyone picture his dog did
anyone talk to you at all
no ever after everyone just shunned you
and ignored like get the [ __ ] out the
ring the next guy's walking up
[ __ ] idiot you have no notion of
fighting ever again huh well
when i did it i just was like all right
then like i didn't really feel much huh
yeah like i just didn't
feel anything when he fought afterwards
like it was cool that i fought and it
was more of a challenge for me
you know like oh i could do it like
because it's it's it's scary walking
into something like that and then being
like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna fight somebody in
a minute hell yeah like and then you're
walking out and then you touch gloves
and then my first mma fight i had two
kickboxing fights before that my first
mma fight
i was like i'm a kickboxer bro like this
guy's a kickboxer all my pieces full up
and he started throwing at me i was like
this motherfucker's trying to knock me
out
i was like that's dude you're really
trying to hit me dude like i'll talk
about chris that's how i felt about
chris
i thought we were friends i was like
what's up what's up
yo chris was trying to kill you in that
room he was trying to kill you i was
talking
about it and he was like hey that dude
got some hands he ain't no comedian like
he really got some hands and i was like
yeah he does man
he was like yeah he looked like he could
like chunk him and i was like what he
was like chunk him
oh like someone what do you think he's a
[ __ ] savannah
[Laughter]
it's
next time you have them on you just ask
them some [ __ ] in spanish that full
speaks like spanish correct so vaughn's
so crazy because he's like what 40 what
43 44 or something now he's so good
still
yeah yeah when i see his videos i'm like
this fool's [ __ ] fast
hey he always [ __ ] up like savannah's
like what five six he's always [ __ ]
up someone's six foot no he hits
so hard dude i'm telling you i i don't
think i've ever been
so presidential right hard like that
[ __ ] hits so
hard so art so hard i remember we were
sparring one time and he had my
face in the like he put me in the it was
in the small ring so fight academy used
to have a ring literally that was the
size
of like no half the rug like it was like
this like
just the area between us it was like
literally you're just hitting you're
[ __ ] throwing down like that's it and
you got savant in front of you which
even if you hit him as hard as you can
it literally does nothing bro bro
he started lighting me up yeah at one
point he had his [ __ ] hand
on my face in the turnbuckle like in the
wwf turnbuckle
slammed right into it saw him
uppercutting me like he was like winding
up
and i would just see his teeth like like
planes came out of him taking slavery
out on my face bro like it was like it
was
like dude it was just beer
he never spar somebody his size he
specifically chooses people who are huge
he's looking up at him and he head kicks
him like this like [ __ ] and he
just knocks him out his head movement is
nuts
he's like bro he's super good he's just
always i think he's always down to scrap
that's his thing though
you could tell he's been fighting his
whole [ __ ] life yeah i love that guy
he's scary bro he scares the [ __ ] out of
him yeah he used to hate
every time he all right because he picks
you no one in the rotation everyone's
trying to avoid him
he would shout you out like all right
pat like you mean you and i'm like and
you're all right
remember that martin luther king cafe
guy the deal everything is named out of
providence like bro what's going on
to the face
by any means necessary [ __ ] by
any means necessary dude
he's like yo don't fight this well this
was a [ __ ] superhero yeah he's a
civil rights
action figure in this yeah my [ __ ]
kobe head butt
dude the mamba headbutt wow
he's like an anime character he just
shouts out every single move before he
does it
actually also flew in japanese yeah i
don't know if you guys know that
people love him in japan he said like
when he fought in japan like japanese
people would go up to him and they would
take pictures of them yeah and then they
don't know who he is dog i saw an old
video
because i guess he was like yeah they
would come up to me and rampage
and just take pictures of us and then
just run off they didn't know who they
were or i think it's rare to see some
black people too like
oh okay there's some guys there uh
training in the l.a or pasadena hit up
savant young
yep this will get you looking nice if
you look at his client's noise his
clients look [ __ ] dope but be ready
to actually fight though because he'll
actually if you really want to learn how
to fight hit that
dude yeah you could really teach us a
get down in there yeah yeah you can tell
he loves
i think he really enjoys watching people
get better like that's his thing and
right now i think for him it's like he's
he's really finding a stride in the
privates because
for him i think he just needs to be more
hands-on with people because in classes
you don't really get that sometimes
so i feel like for him he's really
hitting a stride of like yo i really
just want to work with it looks like he
doesn't allow people to
like get away with small [ __ ] he wants
to fix every little so much easier that
way with one-on-ones
yeah because when you have a group class
and you tell people to do this they'll
either try to do it
or just be like cool and then do
whatever the [ __ ] that they were doing
which is fine but also very
frustrating this is for slavery
[Laughter]
like i'm just like this is like
character 1991
i wasn't responsible i wasn't there i'm
sorry
i'm mexican i'm on your side [ __ ]
you guys start speaking to spanish so he
understands please no
that's spanish
by the way it's only english with the
mexican mexican spanish accent
please no he's like whoa you speak
spanish
i love watching his videos though man
just if you go on savant's videos just
look up his clips of him just [ __ ]
[ __ ] people dude yeah he's a beast
dude he's a [ __ ] because i would
say hey
savannah once you put eclipse of you
getting hit like good luck finding those
clips
and if they are people are like this
yeah they're so scared of hitting that
ball yeah
he rolls punches really well his head
move is so hard to deal with super
illusion he just knows exactly what
you're gonna elusive and in the
in the poc in your face yeah that's
master splinter bro
he's black jeremy stephens dude yeah
it's what he is he just throws bombs
when i saw an old video of him it was
like i looked up on youtube before i had
him on the podcast
yo that dude was jacked yeah
it was so scary yeah frightening dude
like six-pack just
his arms look like [ __ ] bowling balls
when he was in fight shape
and he would like coach he was so scary
he was like absolutely frightening hell
yeah once he retired and he just was
like yeah i just like teaching out like
thank god yeah he he got he got the
demons out
look up one video of him knocking out
this dude named mike
guyman oh apparently he told me on the
podcast mike gaiman was talking a lot of
[ __ ]
which actually motivated him to [ __ ] his
ass up he like broke his jaw in like
eight differently he hit him so hard he
actually had uh
a brain fluid leakage when he hit him
when he hit him
okay so when he hit him the first time
he was out on his feet
boom and then he hit him again super
hard when he was on the ground which was
even more devastating like this
dude the reparation for the reparation
he jumped up in the air and then just
mlk right there
for that fight i was in um i was in
college and i was sitting in a chemistry
class
and i'm sitting in the back and i'm
watching it on like i think at the time
was streaming on like spike tv or some
[ __ ] it was in bellator
and i'm sitting down dual class is going
on and i'm like oh [ __ ] because the
first round savant was like
he got taken down and was being held
down and then the second round
i was like [ __ ] i hope he doesn't get
taken down again and then he knocks him
out i literally jumped up like oh [ __ ]
and i just sat right back down in class
like because
class was going on yeah i was literally
supposed to be [ __ ] paying attention
that was the
first bellator fight i've ever seen and
it was uh that's the only reason why i
recognized savant
because i remember this guy killed a man
yeah he literally
murdered killed when i first started uh
training at fight academy like my first
day going in i thought
don't be mad at me savant but this is
you know this i've said this to you many
times and he looked at me like he was
gonna punch my face
i thought savant was melvin manhoof
yeah i can see that but he's not so if
you look up savant young and melvin
manhoof
i guess they're not the same person [ __ ]
animals but they're just like amazing
yeah and they would find japan and they
were like the guys that would just [ __ ]
people up and knock people
dead and i thought that was him i feel
like savannah could still give people
trouble to this oh
yeah bro hey people i think till he's
like
almost on his deathbed he will be able
to give you trouble he's one of those
old dudes where like he'll get up off
the chair
at 70 and still [ __ ] crack the [ __ ]
out of you so so his his coach is
antonio mckee
who his son fights in bellator right aj
mckee who's fighting
for the uh bellator before the
championship the one million dollar
prize grand prix oh [ __ ] and he's gonna
fight patricki
pitbull i think oh is he bro i remember
seeing this guy aj mckeefe all right
his name yeah aj is a beast he used to
fight at proving grounds so the same
fight cards that nick would fight on i
would see that dude fight and it was
like
back in the day way back in the day and
then i'd start seeing this dude on
bellator
knocking everybody out people like holy
[ __ ] dude and he's
and savant well they're gonna bring
savannah into to mimic picture key
pitbull and [ __ ] because
like they have a very similar like dutch
style kickboxing yeah yeah yeah
so he's gonna be helping him out with it
but uh that's awesome that is awesome
it's so crazy seeing all the guys that
we fought like amateurs with
that fought on the same fight card like
local fight cards who are in the ufc
like
it could have been you dude what
happened i wasn't into it
like the homie jalen turner he i had my
first fight
and he had his first fight on the same
uh proving grounds card he fought right
after me
and he's the guy that just knocked out
brock weaver uh jalen turner's super
long and lanky right yeah
spider yeah yeah the tarantula he's
beast
he's he's a [ __ ]
and like seeing him fight in the ufc is
like this is crazy
dominic reyes fought in the same local
cards that like
we would see him fight and like now he's
so you're saying you are dominic i'm
dominic reyes and he's
he's also related to my jiu-jitsu coach
by like some weird like second cousin
[ __ ] oh uh
oh everybody likes to claim uh something
when they're famous or some [ __ ] yeah
he's actually
my cousin's third wife's brothers
sisters best friends
sisters brothers cousins ex-boyfriends
yes
uncles he also had sex with my
girlfriend so technically we had sex
so
and that's that's that's a real fighter
stuff that is real fighter [ __ ] right
yeah that's just let me bang bro
let me just let me bang let me
just let me bang bro that's like have
you guys ever you guys know that clip
right
what you never seen that clip on the
ultimate fighter just let me bang bro
these two guys are drunk and they were
like the douchiest bros of like all time
so bad and they're drunk in the house
and he was like punching walls
for his name he fights some bare knuckle
fight or something like that he was
never very good on that show
yeah and he's like and there's like he's
i'll fight him right now
julian lane julian lane that's right and
he's like crying because he wanted to
fight somebody he's like just let me
bang bro
like please uncomfortable clips i've
ever seen in my life and then the homie
that he's like that's holding him back
from fighting
is this canadian dude but like a total
like bro like oh dude like what's up
dude
and he's like i do let you bang bro i do
let you back and he's like holding him
bro
in his shoulder just let me play him and
he's like and he's like i do let you
bang bro i do like
you but what the [ __ ] you don't know
i've never seen that whoever's watching
at home bring that [ __ ] up right now
dude right here let me bang this
this is the one that you just touched
and you released that is your phone
yeah dude [ __ ] jackass i can't
believe you've never seen i remember
like junie browning
having moments like that chris lieben oh
do you remember ferguson was a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] on that show dude he's
crazy
he made a comment about somebody's like
dead kid or something i forgot what a
person right yeah
yeah was like really really like
everybody was like yeah
he crossed the line like someone's yeah
like exactly they want you to be a good
father to your kid you
[ __ ] or pass i'm like oh bro holy [ __ ]
dog that was a little much
man like relaxed guy dude the other the
best
what a sick burn though the other one on
top of this was the other guy that
is a resilient dude you better check
your underwears oh
everybody's like what the [ __ ] did you
just say what was that he said
you better check your underwear because
i'm going to [ __ ] you we're like
and that's dope i'm like what does that
translate into portuguese because i
don't think it translates well in
but that's pretty tight though like your
underwear because i'm gonna [ __ ] you
yeah that's dope cause that's that's a
real [ __ ] you better check your
underwear check your own drawers
tell me what this is something else in
portuguese what does that mean
probably people what message were you
trying to convey my man people who
understand portuguese are like whoa
that's actually really good that was
hard that was hard
yeah he actually does want to [ __ ] you
yeah
oh no you're like oh everyone in brazil
is like oh he told him about checkers
oh i do remember seeing this but the
mohawk dude
i do
bro that's the intro to a gay porn
already oh yeah
and he goes let me bang again bro that's
like a gay dude that's just been like
the receiver the whole time in the
relationship and he like wants the pitch
let me bang bro that [ __ ] was like dude
where's my car [ __ ] yeah that was yeah
that's out of a [ __ ] movie let me
bang bro
it's too comedic where it's like i can't
believe this really happened god what is
that and it gives fighters a really bad
look it reminds me of those like fights
you know those dudes at bars where
they're just like
yo hold me back bro cause you don't want
to see what i'll do you don't hold me
back that's my move that's my move
these hands are registered weapons dude
that's what i say that's what i tell
people
people ever have to hold you back in a
fight before no because i'm always like
man [ __ ] you and i leave and i'm like i
should have beat that guy's ass and you
disengage and you talk about the podcast
wait till i talk wait till i go on geez
brain i talk about what a dick you were
i love it when people have to hold you
back because i ain't gonna do [ __ ] yeah
it just makes me look
tough you know that's my [ __ ] dude
you'll hold me back and i'm like yo
what's up what's up no let's just get
out of here dude you're like that's your
hand that's your hand
can't please please
says that but then he stabbed somebody
in the face you know i was eight come on
that's different people don't forget
never forget remember you shoot your
pants in the third grade yeah you're
poopy pants guy
yeah i've never shat in my pants ever
yeah you're not
never i've ever ever you never see your
pants we're not living
one time i almost did and it was a very
shameful moment
because i shoved the kid so [ __ ] hard
in a jack-in-the-box
like straight up you shoved them so hard
that you [ __ ] your pants
i had like what did you do to this guy
i had like some massive diarrhea coming
you know when that's just knocking at
the door
yeah and you can it's like right it's
like exactly it's very shaky like it's
gonna happen
you don't know if you're gonna make it
to the toilet right have you seen that
door and that locket is held by a
cheetah yeah yeah yeah
that is the exact representation
that is one of the funniest me yeah i
don't know why that's so funny but it's
so funny that is how close i was to
[ __ ] myself right
and so my side hurts i'm like [ __ ]
i'm in k-town and there's like a
jack-in-the-box in k-town that's [ __ ]
ghetto
so i'm this close to [ __ ] myself
it's literally just like about to leak
out
i run up i try to open the door i know
that i see this thing
and there's a [ __ ] coin slot there i
don't have [ __ ] coins on me right
and so i had to go up and i was like
listen i i'm not gonna i'll buy whatever
food that you want
i need to use the bathroom they're like
all right cool you can just use this
washer
it's like the washer that you [ __ ]
tighten the screw with cool there's
another kid who's about to put his coin
in
i never felt so i'm not even sure if i
told the story but i felt so ashamed
i literally stiff-armed this [ __ ]
four-year-old child
i shoved this kid with the force of a
thousand waterfalls
that's a haikus you're very poetic
right now you channeled it dude like a
leviathan from the walter falls
i stiff-armed this kid so [ __ ] hard
he hit the wall and i think his head
went but home
and i was like i'm so sorry but the
washer went in
i almost missed the toilet like i
actually i did miss a little bit so
there was like
[ __ ] a little bit all over the [ __ ]
toilet that's a good one that's a
trailer
couldn't [ __ ] just started flying out my
ass wow
and i shoved that kid and i stayed in
the bathroom for another 10 minutes
longer because i was so ashamed yeah
because i didn't want to come out and
see this kid with like a bloody face
from me shoving his bodies through the
wall like there's a there's a print of a
small chip
you want to hear that this is the
funniest part this is a hundred percent
true so when i finally come out right
like there's like no color in my face
like just sweating pale as [ __ ] yeah
his parents are visibly upset because
they want to know who the [ __ ] struck
their child
yeah right like that was the crackhead
over there i come out
i'm talking about pale as [ __ ] because
i'm i was sick i was actually it turns
out i had the flu so i was like [ __ ]
sick and i come outside disgusting
and they're like hey did you hit my kid
right it was this
it was a uh a lady like a lady and then
it was
her either her husband or boyfriend who
the [ __ ] it was right how much did you
weigh at this time oh i was like 270.
easy damn you're big
yeah and i shoved this little 10 pound
child away like
nothing like literally like i was trying
to kill this kid
and so i [ __ ] came out and they're
like hey did you did you
push my kid and i was like i'm so sorry
like i
i'm very sick right now and i literally
[ __ ] all over the place
and i had to use the bathroom and he's
like i got you man
he literally looked at me and he saw
like how [ __ ] sick i looked and he
goes
okay i got you man it's all good this
kid's crying you want to talk about
the toughest parents on earth right yeah
look at this kid he goes
stop [ __ ] crying it's okay man don't
quit tripping because because what's
more universal
feeling across language barriers
cultural differences
then about to [ __ ] your [ __ ] pants
and i think it's also because
i look like i was on the verge of crying
myself i was hyper apologetic
i wasn't arguing yeah you know i'm just
like i'm so sorry but i had like i
literally [ __ ] all over the toilet so
that's why i was in there for so long i
was cleaning up all my [ __ ]
i'm like explaining to this guy please
and he's just like
i got you man he gave you a hug he was
like he basically called this kid a
[ __ ]
yeah because grown-ass man
yeah and then his wife gave me a heisman
trophy she's like here
this is for you i first placed yeah
please no for you please please no
please no please no please snow
that's gotta be the worst feeling like
when you're not near the home base and
you have to [ __ ]
bro all right it's a little embarrassing
let's go baby i don't even know if i
told you this story
but this is like at the beginning of the
quarantine right like
four months in or when it's like this
shit's like we don't know what's going
on people are dropping dead in the
streets people are scared everything is
really closed
like people will not let you use
bathrooms at all right so i
it's a monday i have to pick up my dog
my daughter lives in oxford in oxnard
that's where her mom lives
she lives on her own in oxnard pays for
her studio
real swanky spot real girl has his own
gym
beautiful pool spa no so her mama's in
oxnard i have to pick her up from there
oxnard's like about an hour and a half
drive if there's no traffic right
i wake up a little late and i'm like
[ __ ] i gotta get there so i i'm hungry i
drink a protein
shake and then i drink coffee because i
like coffee in the morning the worst
combination
protein shake or diet coffee and i
wasn't even thinking i was please make
me sick i should have waited
15 minutes to handle my business then
left right about
35 45 minutes into the drive i i started
feeling it like yeah like oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah and then i i had
forgotten about the quarantine right now
as soon as i start feeling it now i'm 45
minutes like between getting back home
and like about an hour
like 45 minutes getting there i'm in the
middle
and i'm like [ __ ] dude like i gotta say
i got i
must [ __ ] pretty soon like it's a must
[ __ ] i must [ __ ] this is a serious issue
so i start [ __ ] i i pull i pull over
and i'm like i gotta find a place right
like it got to the point where it was
like painful it was like
i cannot hold this dude like some this
is a problem
pull in and i'm like [ __ ] it's covered
like the quarantine and i i go
to this gas station no it closed right
nothing i go to a [ __ ] mcdonald's and
i'm like
please let me use your bathroom and
they're like nah it's closed i'm like
i'll pay
whatever i'll buy anything they're like
no i'll buy all your mcribs
yeah i'll buy whatever they're like no
come back right after and take a [ __ ]
i'm like driving around i find another
gas station i just try to bribe the lady
i'm like lady i'll give you
i was like i need i'm gonna [ __ ] my
pants please like let me
use your bathroom dude i'll give you
bitcoin
i'll give you 100 points whatever you
need to
tell me you need to please
my lord please give me anything
i fed you a pail of water i gave you me
a horse
the [ __ ] is wrong with this bro so
i go i i bribe her she's like i
literally can't let you use the bathroom
because the health department they
figure it out we're shut down like you
can't have a business you're like you
grab her by the collar like [ __ ] no
one's gonna find out so i walk out i'm
like [ __ ] like all right like i'm gonna
[ __ ] my pants like i'm coming to terms
with like
i need to now mentally deal with the
fact that i'm about to [ __ ] my pants
because that's literally
what's about to happen there's nothing
else he's like i'm going to show my last
resort you should have shoved her away
like i did that child
i should have dude i should have shoved
her [ __ ] face i find a trash bag in
my trunk
i go back in i buy some gum not to seem
weird but i steal some napkins from the
coffee thing i put the napkins in my
pocket
i start driving around i'm like i gotta
find an alley i'm gonna [ __ ] in this bag
yep find a cul-de-sac like a little
busted area
and i just go okay what's worse [ __ ]
outside in public where a cop could pull
up and i get [ __ ]
arrested for indecent exposure or [ __ ]
in my car
i shot in my car hey dude you gotta go
you gotta go
let me tell you something when you've
gotta go you gotta go bro i
i from outdoors the little area between
the back seat
and the front like this squatted like
this and shut right into the bag
into the bag and i was praying i didn't
miss that takes precision
that takes courage and it takes timing
you are conor mcgregor of the [ __ ] yeah
i am the conor mcgregor the [ __ ]
you're taking a [ __ ] was the equivalent
of conor mcgregor knocking out you're
still better than bobby lee
because he sat in his car on the seat
yeah and was like just full-on
and let it roll around in the back wow
yeah and then was like
what this is a true story oh my god it
happened more than once apparently
kalila was so mortified she had to get
her best friend and paid her to do it
and she had like a whole hazmat suit and
there was just a rolling [ __ ]
he just sat on the backseat and didn't
even clean it up he just left it there
he
pulled in and was like hey kala i pooped
and that was it i'm sorry and then just
so you're still better than him okay
this is a true [ __ ] story oh my god
i can never and he's done it multiple
times and i've confronted he's done that
multiple multiple times chat
on the back seat yes said [ __ ] it prius
cloth
get out yeah that's the other thing
though at that point i would get out of
the car
if i'm like apparently he was on the
highway oh i would have just burned my
car after that
what do you mean he was on the highway
he pulled over on the highway and just
got in the vaccine
apparently that's what the story was
that shit's so [ __ ]
nuts me and tiff talk about it all the
time i cannot believe that that
that happened i can't believe you went
in to buy something all smooth
and just to steal some napkins just
sweating i would have went in
took the napkins and said this is your
fault you've done this to me
this is you also clearly you should have
[ __ ] in your hand and then put it on the
phone also from her perspective the guy
that was clearly just tripping about
[ __ ] his pants who wasn't willing to
pay whatever price just came back in to
just buy some orbit all chill
he's like what the [ __ ] is this guy
doing i was just looking in the eye it's
like you've done this
this is you this is on you i should have
done the poop is on your hands
is on
you would not lower the drawbridge in
order for me to leave the package in
front of your castle
you sound like jon snow thank you he's
not like [ __ ]
since you have not i felt like i was
driving around with a body
because i wrapped the bag up and i had
to find a place to i literally
anyway what's worse a cop pulling over
you have a dead body or just a bag of
your own [ __ ]
i don't know bro because in the moment
probably your own [ __ ] if i would have
gotten pulled over how do you what if
he would have been like what's in the
bag and then i would have been like you
would you don't want to know that's when
you say a dead body and then he would
have found [ __ ]
yeah he goes come on i would have been
arrested a hundred percent they would be
like we gotta go with the bag of [ __ ]
i'll collect [ __ ] what did you say
a collection you trying to donate you
want empty
i would love a little cop poopy i never
had no cop poopie
bet you some donuts and dale some coffee
some coffee why is he talking like that
the worst feeling in the world yeah
having to [ __ ]
in the middle of nowhere is like and you
don't know where your next poop is you
guys used to pee in bottles and [ __ ]
when you were a kid because your parents
wouldn't pull over
i've i've done that in my 20s i haven't
peed no you're a piece of [ __ ] i'll just
say i lost all respect for you i'll just
pee on the side of the road or peeing
and [ __ ] all over the place this guy
this guy [ __ ] his face while i was
driving like because it was like
just mad traffic and i had to do it so
had to be done
in traffic i had to p really bad and
this is how much i found out that we can
pee
it's a lot more than i actually thought
because i had to pee
into an evian bottle right and how many
hours
it wouldn't stop flowing and i'm like
and i was looking at the p going to the
bottle i'm like
no no no no this bottle is not enough
i'm there reading in my head this bottle
is not enough i need another one
and you know it's super hard to stop
your pee mid flow it is you don't train
that i train that a lot of times i can
stop
i can make a i can do it on beats bro
come on baby come on
i could stop and then go stop and then
go i could do that so how's that penis
cancer going for you huh it's really bad
yeah
that's really bad it's it's inflamed
yeah and how do you feel you're fine
it's just fine dude
it's just pissed off how do you do that
you know what it is yeah you know what
it is not everyone could be a jedi bro
and that's just my secret
but that's not a good talent hey bro
it's being able to
stop and then go yeah stop and then go
oh that's how it is that's how much
[ __ ] focus it it's like the force
dude you know not everyone can do it
do you see how amazed you guys are yeah
i miss alex on this podcast
yeah teeth on your dick is pretty cool
comment below if you guys uh stop your
pee
mid stream no disgusting it's really not
that hard wow you gotta train it it's a
mental muscle that wraps up this episode
of the genius piss podcast hold on
this guy over here dude stop i like how
your only talent on earth is stopping
your pee you [ __ ] loser
and being able to being able to fall
asleep anywhere so oh really great
i haven't been able to do that recently
the [ __ ] narcoleptic piss stopper
piss stopper that's a good one
that's the batman series dude i'm the
villain the poop butt sex guy yeah
i'm the piss stopper and you're the kid
[ __ ] sidekick piss stop a nakalepto
i'm just asleep when i pull up i dare
you to do a crime in front of me i'll
fall asleep
and you have a little motorbike i'm in
your side car yeah and i'm just like
that'd be sick
who's gonna report this crime not
nakalepto i didn't see anything
[Laughter]
well guys you could catch nick the ear
at nick
the ear on instagram he's actually
putting up fitness content now i'm very
proud of him
online nte academy coming in february oh
let's go
let's go and we have patrick.t riley
follow
him everywhere can't wait for kobe to
lift up so we could hit that comedy
scene like a [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah that's right by the way once
this whole [ __ ] lifts up your boy going
back into stand up
let's go hell yeah let's go it's been a
long time man
do it it's time dude we're gonna do a
little genius brain comedy tour baby oh
[ __ ]
it's gonna be fun yes that's gonna be
tight yeah get ready
collect your shits for pat he needs him
come on i need all that
we'll see y'all next time peace